july is black indigenous and people of
color mental health month it's also
known as bipoc mental health month so
the goal is to highlight the unique
mental health challenges people of color
face every day mary jane bellies are
live this morning with one local
non-profit trying to break mental health
stigma and barriers mary jane good
morning to you
john and heather good morning to you
solutions of change provides therapy and
counseling service to those in need in
our community and they're talking about
a very important topic this morning by
poc mental health month and i'm joined
early this morning with lakeisha oliver
who is a therapist lakisha thank you so
much for speaking on such an important
topic can you tell us why it's so
important to break down that stigma
thank you so much for having me this
morning so when we talk about stigma
related to mental health it really is
about stereotypes that people have
created and we've been taught over years
of trying to understand mental health
but not really understanding mental
health so people sometimes have that
idea that people who have mental health
concerns or mental illnesses can be
violent or that they can't be helped and
so it's important that we start to
recognize that they are still human
beings and members of our community and
look just like you and me and maybe just
you and me you know um so that we
understand more that there's the ability
and the need to provide service for
everyone and i know you are trying to
provide and extend that service by
hosting a ton of programs that are
happening this weekend can you tell us
what people can expect so for our fifth
annual healing to help we are talking
about no more shame so the goal is that
we bring people in and have them you
know explore some faith-based ideas
about shame some mental health ideas
about shame and kind of put those two
things together together in a way that
allows us to say you know you don't have
to be outside of mental health everyone
is welcome mental health is for everyone
and it doesn't matter where what space
you find yourself in and the really
awesome part about this event that it's
open to everyone in the community you
don't have to be a person of color to
even come in and check it out absolutely
so the importance is that we want to
provide the service to everyone in the
community and so you don't need to have
you know a specific faith-based practice
that you abide by or a specific religion
that you adhere to we want people to
come in and learn more about mental
health and including the faith-based
portion of it so that you have more
information about how to help those
who are in your family to get more
information for yourself so that you can
be more aware about different topics
surrounding mental health lakisha thank
you so much and again we'll have more
information coming up on our website at
eight newsnow dot com reporting live
mary jane ballesa live local now